>> Randy: SET TO DROP THE PUCK
IN GAME TW
NATHAN MacKINNON!
AND AGAIN, THE AVALANCHE WITH
THE FIRST GOAL OF THE GAME ROOMT
DRIVES THAT RELEASE PAST THE
FORSBERG NOW ON HIS FOREHAND GOT
THAT THROUGH.
SAVE BY KUEMPER.LLE NET.
COLORADO RIGHT BACK TO WORK.
BIG SAVE BY INGRAM AS HE GOTAT.
>> Randy: J.T. COMPHER BACK AT
THE GOAL LINE.
UP BY MacKINNON.
>> Randy: PREDATORS WITH THE
HERE'S BREAK. AWAY.
CHANCE FOR MCCARRON, GOES TO REN
AND STOPPED BIRNG.
BUMPS IT BACK.
MAKAR WORK OFG THE RIGHT POIND
IT SEEMS NO MATTER WHERE HE IS
ON THE ICEIN, MAKAR AGAIN,
THAT PASS DEFLECTING OFTEN
LAUZON
PENALTY KILLS HAVE SETTLED INTO
THEIR GAME.
>> Shane.
PICKED OFF.N
STRENGTH BUT NOT OUT OF THE
WOODS.
TOEWS.
THE  SAY, SHANE.
>> Shane: LANDESKOG.
KADRI, INGRATHE PLAY.
CONTACT IN THE CREASE.
THE
THE OVERHEAD.
>> Referee: AFTER
JOSI KEEPS IT ALIVE.!
BY INGRA
HE'S GOT TOEWS.
LEHKONEN PUSHES IT AHEAD.
COLORADO IN THE MIDST OF A
CHANGET HIS FOOTING.
CHIPPED OUT FRONT.
LOOSE PUCK
>> HISTORY
NATHAN MacKINNON CUTS WIDE, CUT,
>> Randy: I LIKE IT.
I'
DUCHENE IN FRONT!
DEFLECTED BY GRANDLUND AND
GRAN.
FORSBERG.
CALE MAKAR WINS IT IN OVE